I'm Rick ray I'm the director of the new
film lynching Charlie Lynch that's going
to be released on 420 this is the story
of Charlie Lynch who ran a medical
marijuana dispensary in San Luis Obispo
for quite a few years and was recently
arrested by the federal government put
on trial and not to give away too much
but very much a victim of the drug war
today I became interested in the film
because reasontv hired me to do a short
piece about Charlie Lynch I went up and
you know the producer said we're going
to be meeting someone who runs a medical
marijuana dispensary so in my mind I
kind of had thought okay he's a bit of a
STONER probably he's kind of a hippie
maybe sort of a free spirit and what I
met when I met Charlie Lynch was a
completely different kind of man the
kind of person who you you know you
would trust babysitting your kids who
looks just like an ordinary businessman
and essentially acts very much like a
regular pharmacist you know simply
wanting to dispense medicine to patients
and do it you know the right way into
illegally and that's who I met so the
disconnect was huge I went into that
interview and I thought wait a minute
this is Charlie Lynch he's never had a
traffic ticket he's never violated any
law you know and here he is about to go
to federal prison I simply can't believe
this that led me to pursue his story now
for the last four years and really get
close to his life and watch as his life
has come unglued and now he faces a
lengthy prison term what happened was
that most people in the community
accepted the dispensary they went there
for their medical medicinal marijuana
even the local police in the city where
we were hands off about it and Charlie
ran it as a tight ship people would come
in with bad IDs or what looked like fake
prescriptions and he would turn them
away he had strict rules he had rules
about people congregating outside people
consuming the substance anywhere in the
area he wanted to be a good neighbor a
good businessman
and he wanted to be responsible but the
local sheriff up in San Luis Obispo took
an instant dislike to this enterprise
and for whatever reason he sent we
believe many undercover people in to try
to get a probable cause on Charlie on a
state level and from what we gather no
one was able to get probable cause no
one was able to catch Charlie doing
something that would have crossed the
line so frustrated the sheriff called
the feds he called them and he said you
know we need we need to work together on
this and so the federal the feds came in
and rated Charlie's dispensary they
raided his home they put him into a
Federal Detention Center and now they
put him on trial and he's going to
federal prison Charlie Lynch's plight is
a small example of the great chasm
between the federal government and state
law and it's it's as if mom says you
can't put your hand in that cookie jar
and dad says hey it's perfectly okay to
put your hand in that cookie jar who are
you supposed to believe what are you
supposed to do and Charlie Lynch is a
victim he's in every man in this sense
that he has fallen into that chasm put
his hand in the cookie jar and got it
cut off by the federal government I
think a lot of us had hoped that the
Obama administration would come in and
that the prosecution and persecution of
dispensaries in California would be
relaxed in fact Eric Holder the Attorney
General made a statement saying that as
long as dispensaries were in compliance
with California law they would not be
harassed by the federal government but
the reality has been very different it's
as if they were paying lip service to
their constituency but the reality has
been the dispensaries continue to be
rated and just last week one of the
colleges that teaches about this
industry oaksterdam university was
raided I you know it astound astonishes
me that the Obama administration would
think that this is somehow appealing to
their voting bloc to be conducting these
kinds of raids so the current state of
medical
marijuana is that it is still in that
dangerous limbo between state and
federal prosecution or permission one
thing we did in this film was we got
very rare access to the the federal
marijuana distribution center at the
university of mississippi in Oxford
Mississippi and this is the one place
that's licensed by the DEA to distribute
marijuana for research we didn't think
we would ever get permission to film
there but we made an appeal to them and
surprisingly mahmood al soo Lee who runs
it gave us permission to come in and
gave us permission full access to see
how that facility is run it's it's it's
a spooky place kind of its this out
building with barbed wire around it and
you go in through security and they have
a giant bank like vault which he has a
combination and they open it and they
open this door and you walk in and you
know here's this marijuana some say it's
is pretty shitty marijuana because it's
grown by the government but nevertheless
this is the facility where they are
allowed to distribute it and conduct
research we also go up to the University
of Massachusetts and we meet Lyle Kraker
who is a botanist who's been teaching
there and has basically been trying to
get a license from the DEA to grow
research marijuana to try to get some
FDA approval of of it as a smokable
substance and a drug and his research
efforts have been largely denied and you
know that's because the University of
Mississippi has this monopoly on medical
marijuana has produced by the federal
government so we go into that and it was
fascinating to get access to that and be
able to cover it the film will be
released on 420 this is not a big
premiere in theaters we're going viral
we're going we hope people will link to
it they'll tweet about it it will be
available for download on amazon
blockbuster it'll be on hulu it'll be on
all your pay TV stations directv dish
network and so on
and it will also be for sale as a DVD on
amazon and elsewhere so we just you know
this film will be out for a long time
and we want to build awareness about
Charlie and his story so that people can
know what's happening and they can take
action and they can make a difference
this has to stop this is you know what's
happening here is putting innocent
people in the chasm between state and
federal government who are just simply
trying to do the right thing it's not
right